the restaurant does my stash dock in
Berlin is holding a beer tasting host
punk vodka has invited his guests to
sample specialities such as champagne
beers sour beers and smoked beers all of
them brewed in accordance with Germany's
purity laws carefully selected dishes
enhance the taste of the beer fushime
inari for children there are different
aromas different layers basically it's
just like a good wine you smell the
bouquet then let the taste roll from the
front to the back of your mouth and you
experience a succession of different
flavors by the lingering afternoon this
is beer for a niche market the micro
brewery trend originated in the United
States but it's also taking off in
Germany I kept testing that missile you
don't just half the stuff and feel
refreshed about the taste very very
diverse it almost has as many nuances as
why you wouldn't expect these things in
a beer notes evocative of light
sparkling Riesling or champagne fruity
notes black currant raspberry the
restaurant features 70 different German
and international beers 0.75 liter
bottle usually costs between 10 and 25
euros busts rarities such as Busch tan
we from Belgium will set you back 60
euros
being idiots we live only diehard fans
are willing to pay 50 euros for a bottle
of beer but beers in the 10 euro price
category have found quite a following
I realize it's something special and
that it comes at a price as memorizer in
order to sample and enjoy exclusive
beers German beer drinkers are
increasingly opting for a pint in a
micro brewery these often have an
attached bar to cater to local markets
places like the Asian boy in Berlin in
the last five years more than 100 micro
breweries have opened in Germany the
owner of errand boy has three different
types of beer on offer all year round
paisa dark beer and wheat beer
all of them unfiltered risotto even a
straightforward Pilsner can vary greatly
it can be just bitter or bitter aromatic
it can have the craziest types of hops
and if it's unfiltered the whole thing
tastes better anyway filtration removes
the different flavors and you really
miss them Mike stove Oscar nom indeed
and be a definitive failure as well as
the three main types of beer on the menu
at Ashland boy there are 15 seasonal
beers such as stout export or ovarian
lager called Madison these bears are
relatively rare in Germany Brewers make
them by hand and with a real passion
onesies didn't get to follow every step
of the production process from the
cracked grain to the finished mash that
you pair with yeast which then slowly
starts to ferment it's this
manufacturing process that makes you so
proud you've made your own product and
you hear people say that's a good beer
dispute the super panache odarg hear
from your tastes a lot better than a
beer from a discount store it's fresh
tasty and a sweeter it's something
specialist to help it's not too bitter
it's very drinkable simply tasty
ravenica
40 its fruitier stronger it tastes like
beer Macomb a beer loss tipsy Bolton via
packets does Meister stuff it's dessert
time chocolate brownies with the various
best a sweet beer with licorice and
chocolate notes the patrons here greed
beer is no simple drink it can be
surprisingly subtle and compelling a
complex